it was my very first time in the Grand
Canyon true backpacking Backcountry
backpacking in the Grand Canyon just
thinking where am I what did I get
myself
into Grand Canyon National Park one of
the most awe inspiring wonders of the
natural
world 29-year-old Allison Redmond and
her father Dennis are here to embark on
an intense 5-day fatherdaughter hike to
the bottom of the big hole my name is
Allison Redmond and I'm from Reno Nevada
I love to practice yoga and I love to
rock climb a friend just took me
randomly one day saying that I was
athletic and I thought I'd enjoy it and
I just kept going to the gym my dad is
super athletic he'll just wake up at the
codon to go hiking he doesn't stop the
last time I tried racing him I broke my
arm well my name is Dennis Redmond and
I'm retired now I live in Scottdale
Arizona we have five children Allison is
number four in line she's just very
active very outgoing and always up for
an adventure so this was going to be you
kind of a father daughter
Adventure they start their descent from
Monument point on the north rim having
done this hike many times before Dennis
leads the group go
k behind his daughter Allison their
friend Scott his daughter Samantha and
her boyfriend Nick the way we planned
our hike was day one park at the trail
head hike down about 5 miles to our
first
campsite although an experienced hiker
Allison has trained hard for this her
first Ascent into the Grand Canyon as I
was hiking I was just amazed just
looking down at the canyon it was just
onping you have all these different
shades of Reds and Hues of greens and I
was thinking to myself like girl you
fall it's not only going to hurt but
this is super precarious the Grand
Canyon is anything but easy it is a
rugged place to hike rocks and Ledges
and whatnot you never know what you're
going to step
into after their descent the group
begins a demanding hike along the red
wall a trail that leads across the
canyon to an oasis called Thunder River
the red walls a couple of miles just
treacherous Rocky there were some Little
Critters some lizards we saw some
condors and it was getting really really
really hot easily 90° plus really
relying on my poles I prefer to use
walking sticks it's nice for support and
if you ever decide to sit down I always
use my hiking pole to just kind of tap
around the Rocks scorpions and any other
venomous type creatures could be
crawling around thinking of things that
may bite you is absolutely part of your
plan I'm Dr Emily Taylor I'm a professor
of biological sciences at calpo the
Grand Canyon area in general is a
biodiversity Hotpot this is a very very
very harsh hot desert so you do tend to
have a number of Highly adapted species
including species there are centipedes
down there rattlesnakes scorpions there
are these water bugs that inflict a
painful bite there are indeed a number
of different things that are potentially
lethally dangerous to a person if they
bite
them then we start making our way
towards Thunder River is is
called it's incredible because you have
this huge Canyon wall and this little
tiny hole where just water is gushing
out of it
ah you did it taking off the pack being
underneath the shade it felt
amazing just a true
Oasis that was my favorite place in the
world at the time we're having lunch
we're making smoothies they just really
enjoyable at this point everyone had
changed out of their hiking shoes and
had put their water shoes on we start
looking at the water fall taking
pictures of the waterfall I see Sam and
Nick is taking a ton of pictures all
right Nick it's your
[Music]
turn I grabbed the phone and I'm next to
this bush it's thorny and super super
green and the whole time I'm taking
pictures picture after picture after
picture after picture okay let me get a
different angle hold on and then that's
when I took a couple steps
and I feel just this searing pain a
thorn like go in in and come out and I'm
just stumbling forward and just like
what was this it's like when you get
alcohol in a paper cut it's just that
kind of sharp all of a sudden just bam
pain of course I'm going to stub my
freaking toe in the middle of the Grand
Canyon you
okay everybody's coming together to see
what's going on told them like this is
I'm in I'm in a lot of pain and then I
took my shoe off and I looked down at my
toe and the blood looked watered down
definitely thought to myself this looks
weird frankly we didn't know what we
were on to cuz there was just a single
little puncture did she she get poked by
a stick or did she get poked by some
other insect I had no idea what had
injured me no sights no sounds just the
instant searing sensation it was just a
huge
mystery Spirit fishing for me is a the
coolest sport in the world you're in the
water you're holding your breath trying
to make as you little disturbance as
possible surrounded by all the life and
seeing all the beauty Nature has but you
want to catch fish well there's risks
you're willing to take I've been doing
my whole life I guess it's bound to
happen Mexico's Yucatan Peninsula famous
for warm Waters and sundrenched Resorts
a popular destination for fishermen from
all over the world like Houston native
Jonathan shonan who has been fishing
here since he was a kid my name is
Jonathan shonan I'm originally from
Houston Texas and my mother is
originally from Mexico City so it was
cool because I grew up in between Mexico
and Houston I grew up in the country so
my whole life was hunting and fishing
and catching armadel anything I could
catch with my hands it was amazing being
able to fish as a child and loading the
boat with big Dorado big white Marlin
and catching not one but a lot Travis
Simmons is Jonathan's childhood friend
and longtime fishing buddy he's always
been like an older brother to me we were
always fishing and causing a little
trouble making a little Ruckus in the
neighborhood Jonathan has always been
like just a free spirit he thrives for
fishing and for adventure and all he
really cared about was like the next
fish he was going to catch it's
2016 Jonathan turns his Lifelong Love
for fishing into a business selling his
catch to local restaurants around Cancun
he convinces Travis to join him so I
decided to move down to Cancun and we
had been fishing every day weather was
gray for a few weeks and then all of a
sudden we had terrible weather for like
a week and a half so I was like Travis
let's go to the Lagoon let's go snook
fishing on a breezy September afternoon
Jonathan and Travis head out to nup
Lagoon an area home to many coveted
species of fish like snook Tarpon and B
bone fish but such Bounty also attracts
a host of predators Jaguars ocelots and
crocodiles frequent the
region we fish for a couple hours and no
luck nothing and I had that feeling that
the fish were going to be stacked up in
this little kind of Cove where it goes
into a freshwater spring so it's kind of
it's a perfect area for all life to be
there we anchored off about maybe 30
yard from the tree line where the roots
and the mang Groves where he's already
changing getting geared up putting his
weight belt on snorkel mask getting his
gun ready he I was like let's get in the
water and it's like oh I don't know he's
like oh no I've done this before it's
okay you know it's no problem I mean
I've heard him say that before and we
find ourselves in situations when I told
Tris if you want to catch the fish you
got to become the
fish there's warning signs
everywhere I mean I love Jonathan like a
brother but sometimes he doesn't have
the best ideas but I didn't want him to
have all the fun so I decided to go
ahead and make the
plunge I didn't pay attention to Travis
you know he stayed on the outside and I
was going deep in the mangroves it was
one of those days I can never forget how
much fish were actually there you go in
and be like schools of 40 50 of them
just swimming right by you it was easy
just pull your gun back and aim and pick
one out and shoot snook you sell
directly to restaurant you can get 180
to 200 pesos and just could stop and
kept on going going going obviously when
that's happening I'm not paying
attention to anything I don't care
what's next to me guessing I had 10 12
fish I my Stringer was pretty much full
I was going back to unload it and my
last dive I didn't see anything so I'm
swimming out coming on the mangr with
the gun to my side ready to take that
first inhale of
air and right as I came up inches from
my face The Croc was staring at me all I
can see was the beak at the front of it
mouth and
then bam got me face
first so um face first looking at Croc's
mouth like completely F I couldn't see
anything just little bit to left and
right the corners eyes and I just felt
like getting hit over the head then
putting in a vice just crunching down
harder and harder and harder I'm
guessing the crocodile is probably 12 to
13t long you know 4 to 500 lb it was
just a solid Beast of a
dinosaur
massive the crocodile 200 million years
of evolution has turned this animal into
one of Earth's most lethal Hunters this
amazing creature can grow to over 15 ft
long swim 20 mph and hold its breath
underwater for up to 60
Minutes Dr Marissa tez is a biologist
and director of the crocodile research
Coalition when you are in crocodile
habitat the last thing you want to do is
attract the crocodiles for example tying
the fish on a line where it's wiggling
and it's dying prey and it's going to
attract the crocodile through these isos
the ingent sensory organ
these are nerve endings that are around
the crocodile's head as well as along
the body so likely the isos of the Croc
are just firing off and he's just going
closer towards the dying fish and
Jonathan's coming towards him and so as
Jonathan's coming up the crocodile kind
of feels something closer for all he
knows it's just a big fish and he clamps
down on
Jonathan I'm face on on the Croc like
completely looking down the
barrel nose everything perfectly
centered inside his
mouth I remember the the smell if it's
just spelled that dirty rotten water
really spelled of
death and just hearing the hissing
noise and seeing the row of teeth into
the freckles and the throat
and then the crunching of my
bones when the crocodile chopped on
Jonathan's head that was anywhere from
2,000 to 4,000 lb per square inch and as
Jonathan is
struggling that crocodile is actually
gripping even more and then it rolled me
I was like oh crap I let go of my spear
gun and uh I took my weight Bel off and
I started bracing myself from the mud as
it was trying to like it rolled me it
kept on trying to pull me under for an
alligator or a crocodile the death roll
it serves two purposes it can either
help take chunks of a large prey or it
could also be used to injure an impul it
so it's crunching down on me so you
think okay I'm going to go for his eyes
so I'm putting both hands up there I was
like realizing the size of its head how
big it was like I couldn't touch so I'm
feeling the eyes and my both of my
thumbs I'm just ging them in his eyes
nothing was happening the eyes are a
vulnerable spot on a crocodile that in
some previous attacks people actually
punching the eyes of a crocodile or an
alligator the alligator or the crocodile
will release unfortunately in this
particular scenario The Croc did not
loosen its grip it's just Biting Down
biting down and I can just hear the
crunching my teeth breaking at the time
I thought it was the Croc's teeth
breaking and he's just clamping down
harder and harder and harder and I'm
seeing the water is normally this kind
of dark tea color and then I'm bleeding
so much that it managed to actually turn
red at an oasis deep in the canyon
Allison Redmond suffers a small
needle-like wound in her foot Unsure how
she got it
looking around I was thinking it was a
thorn from the the bushes that were next
to the creek there's a number of
different things it could have been it
could have been a thorn in the plants
however the Grand Canyon is in the
middle of a desert and so just like
people who visit the Grand Canyon are
going to be attracted to the river as a
place where they can fill up their water
bottles and cool off so are the animals
the water in the Colorado River attracts
tons of wildlife including a number of
different things that are potentially
dangerous but certainly if I was Allison
I would want to be thinking my brain
that's probably a plant because
otherwise the actual implications would
mean that I'm days from heal and I've
just been bitten ins by something that
could kill me at that point there was a
lot of pain in my foot and my toe and
looked a little swollen other people at
the waterfall mentioned that they had
seen something called a water Beetle and
I guess these water beetles have a
pretty nasty sting I think that the
reason that the group thought it could
be a water beetle is because there was a
single puncture wound which water
beetles can do there's a lot of lore
about water beetles that they're these
crazy predatory beetles that walk around
stabbing people that's not necessarily
true but you know it could have
potentially stabbed her and gotten that
sort of pain reaction but it wouldn't
have been that painful they would never
induce the amount of pain that she was
in my foot is throbbing it hurts so bad
feel I can do this I think I'm going to
be okay but I didn't want to be a burden
on the rest of the group this is where
when you're the father ultimately
whatever happens here I'm going to feel
responsible so I got to start thinking
are we doing the right evaluation they
give Allison basic first aid treatment
but with the day running out it's vital
that they get to their campsite a
strenuous quarter mile hike away so we
decided we're going to continue our hike
CU where were we were out definitely
there was no way anyone was going to get
us out of there I knew that there's no
way that anybody could carry me because
of the kind of treacherous terrain I was
able at this point to still be able to
put my hiking boot on of course I mean
for lack of a better term interrogating
her say what's going on how you feeling
I can do this I I think I'll be okay and
she gets up on her hiking poles and she
just kind of hobbled down she's not
complaining per se at all so that's s
some of those indicators think well
maybe she's hopefully going to be okay I
can feel it swelling I can feel it
getting bigger every step I took Not
only was painful to put weight on but
also extremely heavy every time I picked
it up just never complaining not as if
oh excruciating pain that I can't do
this and no I can go I'll go down to the
next Campground and it's just tougher
Nails this kid Allison keeps on hiking
so sounds like she was a really tough
woman and wanted to just walk it off
which if it was a wasp or a water Beetle
or something she indeed would have been
able to but as time progresses and the
pain becomes really unbearable this is
the first signal that it probably was
something more serious and then as she
continues to hike on it even with a
severe pain of her body is trying to
tell her don't put weight on this foot
see to this injury take care of this
injury that's the purpose of pain in our
bodies By ignoring that we're
ignoring the signal from our body that
something is seriously
wrong despite the escalating pain in her
foot Allison reaches the campsite the
group sets up tents for the night still
hoping this mysterious wound is nothing
and she'll be better come
morning my dad set up the tent we had
figured because of the irritation just
stay off your feet and fall asleep with
your foot elevated I hadn't clued
anybody in that I was worried quite yet
I figured that if I'd let my dad know I
was worried he would go into full panic
mode well I think that what she was
doing was just putting up the tough girl
front I got this she's getting concerned
I you could tell but she was not
breaking down I'll be
fine at this point I thought that I was
going to wake up the next morning and
Hike the rest of the
canyon
that night was Restless my leg was
swelling I was in a lot of pain that's
when kind of fear might have started to
creep in just a little bit I'm sleeping
next to her but all night I'm awake
listening for every move obviously she
wasn't sleeping very well so now doubts
coming on am I am I making the right
decision should I allow this to go on
any
further
I wake up and I get out of my
tent at this point now I cannot walk the
swelling had gone all the way up to my
knee just excruciating pain it was
definitely not a water Beetle when
Allison wakes up in the morning and sees
that her foot is severely swollen 12
hours after the bite the conclusion can
only be drawn that this
was a rattlesnake
bite nothing else would cause those
sorts of symptoms and there is only one
type of rattlesnake that occurs in this
area the Grand Canyon rattlesnake kis
abysus so named after the abyss of the
Grand Canyon that it lives
in the Grand Canyon rattlesnake a highly
venomous pit viper found nowhere else in
the world it can grow up to 4T long the
perfectly camouflaged coloration and
calm demeanor often allows it to escape
detection and unfortunately for Allison
Thunder river is the the ideal hangout
for such a highly evolved creature
within the Grand Canyon Thunder river is
an example of an oasis it's a place that
attracts people who are hikers in the
area it also attracts Wildlife
rattlesnakes are going to be feeding
upon the rodents that thrive in areas
where there's water and indeed also just
drinking from the water and finally
sitting down next to the water they're
going to find a much cooler microhabitat
than they might way up in the hot rocks
in the
desert Allison not knowing that she had
been vated by a r snake I think this
really speaks to that she didn't see the
snake and clearly she wouldn't have
thought it was a r snake bite because
most people think that if it's a r snake
bite there's going to be two Fang marks
and indeed there usually are but
sometimes only one Fang can actually
penetrate the flesh this can happen for
a number of reasons the angle of the
snake's bite the size of the snake and
especially the fact that the fangs had
to go through these water shoes and even
if it was in the back of her mind that
it could be a r snake there's probably
this strong denial by her subconscious
that it could be because a Rous n fight
means your trip is over and let's hope
for the best for your medical care and
even your
survival at this point Allison and her
father are still unaware of what bit her
they just know her injury is getting
worse by the
hour and I looked at it and I said no
we're not waiting any longer call the
militia is the words I used because that
means we need help and they go well you
know maybe we ought to wait to see if
the swelling goes down no we are not
waiting any longer this is it call in
the help I'm just like yep I'm going I
got to go let's make the phone
[Music]
call within the mangroves of Cancun's
nichupte Lagoon a crocodile crushes
Jonathan shonan's head in its
jaws his friend Travis is spear fishing
hundreds of yards away a oblivious to
the life and death struggle I'm fighting
fighting fighting I'm starting to get
physically exhausted and then I remember
Crocs that have a flap their mouth so
they always close that flap when they
eat you know if you push it down it's p
of water gag and let you go I reach
between my face and the mouth slide it
in there and punching it I'm hitting as
hard as I possibly could actually my
hands was completely bruised from
sticking inside his
mouth start starts punching at the patal
valve and the patal valve is similar in
a sense to the lips of a human it
prevents water from going in and it's
another sensitive area many times the
crocodilian the alligator of the
crocodile will let go if you pulled down
the pat valve water would rush in and
the alligator would let
go as I'm reaching down his throat
punching it and the vice is getting
tighter around my jaw and trying to push
the flap down and that didn't work this
whole time he's kind of pushing me back
to the mangroves and second later like
cor my eye I noticed a branch from The
Mangrove managed to break the branch
started hitting the Croc on the head I
was completely on adrenaline I had the
biggest adrenaline High Ever I mean to
snap that branch and it was a big Branch
like my head think about completely I'm
in the BCE I'm just hitting myself like
as hard as I could just over and over
and
over
and finally let me
go so when Jonathan had the branch and
started knocking at the crocodile the
crocodile might have finally just gave
up just simply because it might not have
had the greatest grip on Jonathan given
that Jonathan's head was in the front
part of the
snout and that
relief
and then I just looked down I could see
all the blood everything my teeth
dangling everything just mangled and
then he went back into where it came
from I went the other way and I was
swimming back on my back
yelling gargling noises because my jaw
is completely split in half and dangling
so I'm just making this weird
noise my head is partially submerged my
ears are below the water level but I
started to hear this like kind of
muffled SC scream ah ah ah just over and
over again screaming and I see him
coming out of the mangroves just covered
in blood and his jaw hanging down to his
chest and it looked as if Wolverine had
just went like that to his skull you
know I can see his face like that shock
like what the hell is happening you know
he just charged right to me to come get
me no hesitation I turned him around to
back put him on my chest and and like
start kicking back to the boat as hard
and fast as possible because I didn't
know if that Croc was coming for us to
finish the
job Travis pulls his friend Jonathan
into their boat the damage from the
crocodile attack is
extensive I start checking him making
sure that his main cored artery had not
been severed and I know I have to stop
stop the bleeding I know we got to get
out of here and I know that I have to
find help took his shirt off and wrapped
it around my face pulled the anchor and
I was like his is literally his first
time in the lagoon so I was guiding you
know hey just go here like showing him
where the Marine to go and I'm holding
my face and the shirt just dripping
blood everywhere the boat's just a mess
and it just looked like a murder
scene and I kind of cracked lay the boat
right into the
[Applause]
dock I just started yelling like are you
the me are you the may help me like help
help and I'm telling the people
ambulancia call an
ambulance and he's at this point like he
just looks like he's fading in and out
of Consciousness a little bit I was just
sitting there you know basically
cradling him holding him not knowing if
like he's breathing his last breath
because of the amount of blood
loss after nearly an hour the ambulance
team arrives to help
Jonathan when the pamic got there they
pulled me up they trying to lay me onto
the bed I'm like I'm suffocating cuz I
couldn't breathe CU my tongue and
everything is hting me I couldn't my
Airway is completely blocked off the
communication barrier was definitely a
problem in Travis at the time he did
speak Spanish and I had my jaw ripped
off I'm
mumbling it's rush hour traffic the
middle of Hotel Zone uh everybody's
getting off for work and it's just
Bumper to Bumper the ambulance it was
crazy he's rolling up onto the curb
going around traffic the sirens blaring
I highly doubt this EMT had ever seen a
case this severe with somebody having
their face basically ripped off by a
crocodile I saw my face completely
destroyed in the mirrors of the
ambulance that's when I panicked I
started losing Consciousness at that
moment
at their Campsite in the Grand Canyon
Dennis Redmond makes the call though he
doesn't realize his daughter was bit by
a rattlesnake he knows Allison needs
immediate evacuation using a satellite
Beacon they contact the Canyon's
Emergency Response Center which
dispatches paramedics to the site so my
dad was making sure that he could feel a
pulse in my foot and he had to dig his
finger into my foot in order to find it
that's when I saw concern in his face
because he was like well it's there but
it's faint there's absolutely no
question that a person has been inv
venomed once we see severe swelling and
pain Grand Canyon rattlesnakes have a
really strong venom it's full of
different proteins that are going to be
disrupting the blood clotting Cascade
that's going on in her foot potentially
disrupting blood flow to important
tissues like ligaments and tendons
meanwhile there's also neurotoxins that
are known to be present there could be
serious risks of her losing her ability
to be able to breathe properly when
you're so far away from help and from
antivenom treatment which is the only
way to treat a snake bite this could be
a serious serious problem both for her
actual foot and also potentially for her
life because of the neurotoxins it's
been almost 24 hours since Allison's
bite the paramedic team arrives but
their helicopter can't land this deep in
the
canyon so they turn around and go back a
couple miles to drop off the team the
team then has to do multiple Crossings
in the river in order to get to us so
once the paramedics got there Megan the
paramedic had informed me that she
believed it was a rattlesnake bite this
is when the
first moment of actual fear and panic
actually set in just complete
meltdown finally Allison realizes this
is probably a rattlesnake snake by
Specialists are going to tell you that
the most important thing to do in the
event of a rattlesnake inv venation is
to seek medical treatment as quickly as
possible so the faster you get to the
doctor to get the antivenom treatment
the better all this time goes by with
Allison she's increasing the chances
that there could be this long-term
damage so the paramedics gave me NIV and
they start prepping to fully Me From the
Canyon I'm trying to be calm right I'm
trying to process all of this but when
your child is down you got
to you have to have your
facilities you I can feel it coming back
I mean but you can't can't show it he's
terrified and it's all in his face I
didn't want to freak out if I was
freaking out he would
just couldn't wouldn't be able to handle
[Music]
it a few hours after a crocodile attack
Jonathan and Travis make it through rush
hour traffic to the hospital they didn't
know if I was going to make it because
of all the trauma I had to my head all
the blood loss I have my jaw is split in
half come from here all the way over
here and this where completely ripped
off and plus the bacteria from the
crocodile my brain was just swelling
tremendously when I woke up I didn't
know if I was going to be able to speak
or anything or if I was going to have
brain damage I had no
idea 17 days later I woke up it did such
a fabulous job putting me together my
jaw wasn't wi
shut I couldn't believe he looked as
good as he did uh in that moment so I I
was in shock seeing him I I thought he
was going to be deformed for the rest of
his life like severely deformed and so I
was very surprised they put Humpty
dumped you back together
again back in the Grand Canyon the clock
is ticking and with no place for the
helicopter to land they put Allison in a
screamer suit in order to airlift her
out of the canyon to Higher
Ground so the helicopter came over I was
hooked in Adam was hooked in we get
lifted off and they have us dangling 150
200 feet off the ground of the Grand
Canyon next time I saw
her she was flying down she was flying
stringing 150t rope or so down the Grand
Canyon I'm thinking oh jeez what's
What's happen in here and I'm looking up
and I'm just she just slowly coming down
the canyon in the that moment I was
thinking to myself this is a very bad
situation but this is pretty freaking
cool it's called a screamer suit because
most people are very frightened by
Heights and will scream in it and the
whole time I was
like with Allison on her way to the
hospital the rest of the group hikes on
to their next campsite Dennis stays
behind he will hike out of the canyon
and back to his daughter at Sunrise
there I am 5:00 or so in the afternoon
3/4 the way down to Grand Canyon my
30-year-old daughter she's just been
bitten by a
rattlesnake and when they're gone it was
just me cuz everybody left but that's
when it just that's when I broke down I
couldn't handle it and then it's when I
just said okay I got to let this go
that's where it all comes together
everything comes together and thinking
oh my gosh every every minute counts now
and it's been 24 hours what in the world
decision was I making at this time why
why didn't I do this sooner this this
could to have detrimental
effects when I was in the helicopter the
pain was it's like when whenever your
foot falls asleep but instead of the
pins and needles it's more like
Chopsticks and acid just searing just
like coming in from all sides 20 hours
in the Phenom has probably caused some
severe damage within her foot depending
on how much was initially injected the
swelling is also potentially leading to
compartment syndrome compartment
syndrome is a situation in which the
swelling in certain parts of the foot or
the affected limb can compress blood
vessels and nerves in other parts of the
foot thereby leading to tissue death and
furthermore the venom has probably moved
through her lymphatic system throughout
the rest of her body where neurotoxins
if present could be impacting her
ability to breathe and other factors I
arrive in Flagstaff I get checked into
ICU there are people everywhere people
drawing all over me poking me prodding
me and I'm feeling safe they're going to
give me this antivenom I'm going to get
better so they administer it first with
the micro CHP so gradually over the next
10 minutes I'm I'm feeling weird kind of
fuzzy and kind of heavy I I was just
thinking that oh this is what this is
what antivenom feels like it's it'll be
fine after the 10 minutes they crank it
up because the they feel confident that
I wasn't that I was safe and within
seconds I start to go into an antic
shock my throat is starting to close up
my eyes I can feel them heavy and
swelling I can start to see the skin
around my eyes just swelling shut and at
that point I was like
okay that's it poor Allison the very
thing that is designed to save her
causes an allergic reaction within her
body which is relatively uncommon it
happens in maybe up to 3% maximum
percent of patients and she goes into
anaphylactic shock anaphylactic shock is
when the body responds with an
overreactive immune system to an
allergen in this case some of the snake
venom proteins and goes into shock
meaning that the blood vessels dilate
her blood pressure drops her throat
swells up and she has trouble serious
trouble breathing so in fact in her case
a lot of the things that in some people
are caused by the Venom were caused by
the antivenom and this may have been
because she was allergic to some of the
proteins that are in the antivenom
antivenom is made by injecting small
amounts of Venom into domestic animals
like horses or sheep the resulting
antibodies are then collected and
purified Allison is allergic to to
horses so it's possible that Trace horse
proteins in the antivenom caused her
reaction back in the canyon Dennis is
getting updates from his wife when I got
the the word that she had quote a
allergic reaction I'm thinking oh my
gosh you know that is one of those
moments again
where you just you don't you don't
realize how much you love your children
until you think they're in a position
that they're not going to make it out
alive and it is so it's one of those
things that it's just it you think how
could it be any
worse doctors are able to stop the
anaphylaxis but without an effective
treatment the Venom continues to spread
throughout Allison's body they
immediately call Phoenix Banner hospital
to see if they had the other brand of
antivenom uh luck they do and back on
another helicopter to Phoenix and they
started all over
again the next morning at first light
Dennis begins a solo track out of the
canyon he never hiked so fast in his
life when I left at 5:30 that morning my
intent was to get to the hospital that
was where I was going and I wasn't
stopping and the whole time I'm getting
some of these text and things about
what's going on you know they got her
settled down they got her shipped to
Phoenix by helicopter so I'm getting the
up
dates this time doctors in Phoenix
administer Allison another
antivenom they are made differently
different extractions different
antibodies and one of them is made with
horse antibodies and one of them is made
out of sheep or goat antibodies which
she has no negative reaction
to Allison her mother and the medical
staff breathe a huge sigh of relief I
just shoot up the mountain and I'm up at
the top by noon the next day by then
Allison's getting out of the
hospital thankfully the second round of
antivenom treatment is so successful
Allison is released from the hospital
that
afternoon so I jumped in my truck threw
everything in there and then I just
headed home by the time I got there
she's there at home sitting sitting on
the couch with her foot up oh hi
Dad hi
Dad is that what you got to say it was
it was quite the
journey back in Houston Jonathan
shonan's recovery is nothing short of
astounding when it was ripped apart all
my bones were together that's why they
were able to piece me back basically
perfectly and this is next to the chotic
artery where the doctors were just
amazed that they could see
it if it would have been millimeter over
it would have cut the vein I would have
died out like that
yes Jonathan was in crocodile habitat
but something else we have to consider
is in these very touristy areas such as
Cancun there has been an increase of
negative interactions between humans and
crocodiles and some of those negative
interactions it's because people are
feeding crocodiles these animals become
habituated and they lose their fear of
humans
with that loss of fear they're more
likely to be bold and aggressive and
that's when an attack can happen a
general rule no matter where you go in
the world do not feed the wildlife
because you might enjoy having a nice
selfie that you can put on social media
not realizing you get to leave and go
back to your nice safe home and you have
increased the danger of a particular
community I need water in my life
doesn't matter where it's at I just want
to be close to it lot people talk to me
oh I can't believe the crocodile how
could you be in the water well really it
just made me
stronger my family I promised them I'll
never go spear fishing in the lagoon and
I kept that promise I've been in there
swimming but not spear fishing so I've
kept it pretty
in after the rattlesnake bite Allison
faced months of physic IAL
Rehabilitation just to walk again but
one question Still Remains how did a
group of such experienced hikers
misdiagnose Allison's rattlesnake bite
people are very reluctant to think that
they could have been bitten by a
rattlesnake unless they saw the snake in
reality it can actually be really
different she's walking through brush
it's loud raging River she doesn't hear
even the snake moving she doesn't hear
anything and it happens so rapidly that
it makes sense that a would never have
even seen it she would just say hey what
was that and then 10 steps later hm that
hurts a little bit and then by the time
she's really thinking oh shoot that
could have been rattlesnake that snake
is miles behind her according to Dr
Taylor Allison likely wasn't the only
one surprised by this encounter so
imagine the ear rattlesnake hanging out
under the brush can't really see very
well because you're covered in this
brush you have no ears what you do have
is a strong sense of smell and taste and
then you have this sense of vibration I
think it's definitely possible that
because of this Raging Water the snake
didn't have the opportunity to sense
Allison's footsteps as she approached
the rattlesnake is sitting there quietly
Allison comes up neither of them sense
the other one and when she stepped on or
near it it bit to defend itself 6 months
later Allison is nearly fully recovered
with no intentions of letting this
incident slow her down I'm back climbing
back practicing yoga and and I will be
going back into the Grand Canyon in two
weeks from this being filmed I just
psyched to give the canyon another
go less than a year after the bite
Allison returns to the Grand Canyon
completing one of its most difficult
hikes the n kib Trail with Dad by her
side but she will never forget how
fortunate she is to be alive just my
look right me being allergic to anav
Venom and me getting bit by rattlesnake
in the Grand Canyon both I would have
had better chances of winning the
lottery it was supposed to be the father
daughter Venture you know with friends
and
but sometimes life makes a little twist
so we have a no whole new adventure to
talk about and to share with people say
you learn something from this if you
will I think this entire experience has
definitely strengthened the bond between
my father and I he checks in more he
usually a super fast hiker he's usually
leading the pack like first one up at
the summit and now like he hangs back a
little bit when we're hiking together a
little bit more than he used to I like
[Music]
that